pont alors justement monsieur lui je
vous propose de revenir
nouveau rebondissement dans une enquête
menée précisément par les gendarmes
l' enquête sur le meurtre du petit
grégory près d'epinal avec l'inculpation
aujourd'hui d'un cousin du père de la
victime bernard laroche un reportage de
fr3 dans six de bernard laroche
depuis 48 heures les gendarmes avaient
acquis la certitude que l'umq aboutir
rapidement et qui ne leur manquait
désormais qu'une petite pièce du puzzle
pour comprendre et dénouer une affaire
qui secoue depuis trois semaines les
penche sur vologne et des petites
vallées vosgiennes environnantes
cette pièce les enquêteurs allaient l'a
trouvé en interrogeant ce matin muriel
une jeune fille de 15 ans elle est la
belle-soeur de bernard laroche le témoin
numéro 1 mise en garde à vue avec sa
femme née prédit dernier avant d'être
relâché le lendemain
muriel avait donné un alibi le jour du
crime pour la roche un alibi qui
devaient se révéler faux ce matin
pendant deux heures et demi jean michel
lambert le juge d'instruction a
reconstitué avec muriel le trajet
supposé de l'assassin de grégory et à
l'issue de la reconstitution le juge
déclaré je suis optimiste
on brûle à la gendarmerie de bruz hier
il est alors 12 heures et tout va
s'accélérer
le juge d'instruction et les gendarmes
prennent la direction de grand-champ
vologne et vont arrêter bernard laroche
sur son lieu de travail aux
établissements cancel la roche on
ressentira les menottes aux poignets
en fait on allait là pour plus tard et
de bonne source muriel aurait reconnu
s'être trouvé dans la voiture de la
roche avec son fils sébastien
tous les trois serait allé chercher
grégory pour se rendre derrière la
caserne des pompiers de docelles bernard
laroche se répartit quelques instants
avec grégory il est revenu seul pendant
plus de trois heures il sera interrogé à
la gendarmerie d'epinal assiégé par les
journalistes à 15 heures bernard laroche
quittera la gendarmerie pour le bureau
du juge
l'entretien durera 30 minutes il en
ressortira inculpé d'assassinât qu'est
ce qui vous a permis un témoignage
capital est en partie un rapport
d'expertisé
mais les résultats partiels ce
témoignage celui de muriel exacte et ce
qu'elle vous a dit exactement ça je n'ai
pas besoin de vous le dire mais secret
d'instruction et muriel a accompagné par
la roche sur les lieux du crime
invité dans la voiture et sébastien son
fils aussi oui c'est lui qui a servi
d'appât
pour vraiment vraiment pas vraiment dire
ça est-ce que j'étais dans la voiture
est-ce que vous allez procéder à
d'autres inculpations dans l'état actuel
du dossier jo l'ignorent totalement
reste que bernard laroche a nié tout au
long des interrogatoires criante au
journaliste un énigmatique pour nous
mais vraiment dans le coup et si les
enquêteurs sont se soient persuadés de
tenir l'assassin de grégory reste
maintenant à comprendre les mobiles du
crime